Welcome to Ear Biscuits.
I'm Link.
And I'm Rhett.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting
we are going to be catching
you and one another up
on our Thanksgiving break.
I'm thankful.
I'm thankful to be here with you, Rhett.
Thankful to be back.
I'm thankful that you are listening,
you who are listening.
Man, what if you're
drivin', you're joggin',
sometimes I just like to think
about what people are doing.
Somebody's on the elliptical 'cause I tend
to do a lotta podcast
listening on the elliptical.
You know, when we were
recently do our little tour
and we would both go to the gym together.
Well, we wouldn't go to the gym together.
We would go to the gym at the same time.
We were like ships passing in the night.
You would do your gym thing
and I would do my gym thing
and I noticed, you know I came up to you
and actually I came up to you and told you
that I'd just seen J.J.
Redick on the elevator
and didn't say anything to
him because I didn't realize
it was him at first and I kinda froze
and then he got off.
Uh huh.
You, my friend, were on the treadmill,
not the elliptical.
Yep.
Now, I do the elliptical
because it's low impact, right,
so you don't have to worry
about any sorta knee,
back, all those things.
What's your treadmill thing?
My treadmill thing?
Well, I'm a little
intimidated by the elliptical.
I don't know.
I've never done the elliptical.
The only elliptical.
We have an elliptical.
We owned an elliptical.
Yeah, I remember, back
when we were in like
the Lillington basement, Rhett shows up
one day, he was like, I'm doin' it, man.
I'm ordering an elliptical.
And there's actually
an episode of the Rhett
and Link Cast Live where we.
Great show.
Where we were talking about the fact
that you had just gotten this elliptical
and I think the elliptical
was like on the set
and I might have used it during that show
and I never used it after that.
I'm not gonna say you didn't
use it after that either,
but you didn't use it after that either.
I used it more than you did.
I don't know, somethin'
about it intimidates me
and there's no.
I did 45 minutes on the
elliptical just this mornin'.
I just did like, well.
I listened to what I'm going to wreck
at the end of this podcast.
Okay.
'Cause it was exactly that length.
Another podcast?
Uh huh.
That's dangerous, man.
You start to recommend another podcast.
They barely listen to this one.
You get podcasts in people's blood,
you wanna keep it in their blood,
even if it's other podcasts.
That's my theory.
We should be secure enough
in what we're doing here
that people can take it or leave it.
I am.
But, to answer your question,
I don't really have,
I mean, I don't get on
a treadmill, much less
an elliptical, in my normal workout.
That's not a part of what I do at my gym.
I don't do it when I'm with my trainer.
I only do it when I'm
trying to get extra cardio.
I just, yeah, I just did it as a warm up,
but there's like a screen and you can put.
A hike in there.
You can put like you're
runnin' in Rice Canyon.
You can run on the elliptical as well.
Oh, you can?
It's the same, it's literally the same
except one is like super low impact.
And you know what?
I'm nervous the whole time,
especially when you came
up to me and you scared me.
All of a sudden outta
nowhere you were like, hey,
in my ear.
But, the other thing
is with the elliptical
the things you're holding
onto with your hands
are monitoring your heart in the moment
and giving you feedback, giving you
the accurate calorie counts.
Yeah, 'cause I don't
hold on to that railing
when I'm running.
I see no advantage to the treadmill
unless I'm missing something.
I mean, you maybe look cooler.
Did I look cool?
No, you didn't.
Okay, well then there's not that.
But, I mean, maybe people in general do.
Can I make a observation?
I'm also nervous that I'm gonna fall off
the elliptical and face plant.
So, I said elliptical,
but I meant treadmill.
I should be on the elliptical.
I'm intimidated by the treadmill.
Well, next time I'm at a gym I'm gonna get
on the elliptical.
Can I make an observation?
Come join you on the elliptical,
me and you on one elliptical?
Sure, I bet you we could do it.
That'll draw attention.
Do that.
What if I showed up at your gym and like,
we literally did everything in tandem.
It'd be tough for two men to be
on an elliptical, but
I'm sure we could do it.
Okay.
Let me make an observation.
Hey, by the way, let's
make a note of that.
Before we forget, I just
wanna make a mental note
to add that to the list.
You know, we've got a running list.
You know what I'm talkin' about.
I was already thinkin' it.
We're gonna go to your
gym and we're gonna see.
It's not 2020 yet, but
I have, I'm thinking
that maybe in 2020, on the podcast
I'm gonna stop wearing headphones.
Thanks for noticing.
It's hard to notice
'cause your hair is so,
I mean, they could've
been hiding in there.
But, I'm gonna make an observation.
You are talking so much
louder than you would be
if you were just having
a conversation with me.
Really?
It makes me think that I must be talking
more quietly than I normally do
because I don't ever think
that you're talking loudly,
but like, you're talking
louder than a normal person
would talk to a person this close to them
and it's because you have headphones on.
And it's weird because it
actually, it really pumps
into your ears.
I actually, yeah, I would've
put money on that I'm
talking more quietly.
Am I talking more quietly
than I normally do, Keiko?
'Cause I'm listening to
you through the headphones.
I'm hearing you.
I feel like I'm talking louder in order
to keep up with you.
I've turned my volume down.
'Cause I was just thinkin'
maybe I'm gonna do
no headphones because I
don't really need 'em.
I know how to stay close to the mic.
I use my extra long beard as whiskers
and it makes contact with it.
I know how close I am to it.
All right, so if I'm talking at the volume
that I would normally talk.
You know, this is Link
volume at the beginning
of a podcast.
It's a little louder
than how I'll be later.
You don't sound too loud in general.
Someone who's listening right now wouldn't
think anything of it.
But, I'm just saying, if we were just
having a conversation and
you are 24 inches from me,
you wouldn't be talkin' this loud.
Well, I took my headphones off.
Now, you're talking quietly.
Now you're talking normally.
I'm talking quieter.
Yes, definitely.
Because you were talking like this.
I tend to use the treadmill.
I am intimidated by the elliptical.
Keep talking.
And now, this is, I mean,
I'm just talking normally.
Well, you're definitely louder in my ears
when I have the headphones
on than when I take 'em off.
Uh huh.
But.
Oh, I know you wanna
keep those headphones on.
I actually don't know.
Really?
I don't.
I mean, as long as Keiko has headphones on
and can monitor everything, make sure
that nothing goes wrong.
I mean, we have this mentality that we're,
back in the day it was just us.
Nobody was listening to us, so we had
to know if somethin' went wrong.
All right fine, I'll take 'em off.
But, listen.
Let your hair breathe.
The real reason we're doin' this
is somethin' to do with your hair.
Well, I actually feel
more free without 'em on,
but yeah, it's like because
I have so much hair now,
it does create this
problem that then I have
to try to correct.
Why take the extra time if
it's not doing anything for me?
All right, I'm goin' raw, guys.
We're gonna give it a shot.
See, I think later in this episode,
when I talk about what happened to me
over Thanksgiving, I think I'm gonna get
more introspective.
I think I'm probably gonna
get a little quieter.
But, as long as you remain close
to the microphone.
As long as I remain
close to the microphone
it'll be fine.
What you don't wanna do is go back here.
As long as I'm not, I don't do that.
I'm a pro, I'm a professional.
I mean, sometimes I might go back here
for effect, like ha,
ha, ha, ha, real effect,
and then I come back close like this
'cause I'm also a professional.
All right, let's just see how this goes.
See, Keiko's over there adjusting knobs.
Are you making me hotter?
'Cause yeah, I am talking quieter.
Yeah, uh huh.
Now that I've taken.
See, I would've thought it
would've been the opposite.
Why do I talk louder
with the headphones on?
I don't know and I
don't know if I also do.
Let me see.
I guess I gotta do it now.
Well, you gotta really put yourself.
Man, there's cords.
In a neutral place.
Don' overthink it, just start talking.
So, right now I'm just talking normally.
No, you're quieter.
If I was having a conversation with you,
okay, maybe if I'm emphasizing a point
I would be like okay,
I'm making a point now.
Keep talking.
I'm making a point now and now I feel like
I don't know, maybe I
talk the same exact level.
I feel like I'm talking the
same exact level that I was.
Yeah, that's because it's
not a blind experiment.
You're biased.
No, but I'm trying to respond
to what I was just hearing.
That's not how science works.
No, I'm responding to, I'm putting myself
into the mood that I've been in for years
with these things on.
It's inconclusive.
That's all I'm saying.
Well, what is conclusive
is that you talk louder
when they're on.
Well, they're off.
I don't wanna talk louder.
I'll tell you somethin'
else that's conclusive.
You messed up your hair.
Yeah, see what I gotta do now?
You didn't mess it up.
It's constantly messed up.
No, no, if I kept it on for longer,
and honestly, that's
not the primary reason.
I just sat down and I
looked into the monitor
and I was like, we don't need headphones.
We don't need 'em.
Until we realize we do.
You know what?
Let's move on 'cause I got a milestone
that happened to me this morning,
I wanna share it.
Okay.
And then, at the end
maybe we can come back
and say, you know what, this is good.
This morning marks a moment in my life,
a culmination of a project
that I've been investing
myself in for months, over
six months of investment
has led up to this
morning and what happened.
Okay.
And, I'm extremely proud of myself.
I finally achieved it.
My daughter drove herself and her brother
to school themselves, herself.
That's right, my daughter,
Lilly, 16 years old,
has a bonafide driver's license.
She got in a car.
Her brother, Lincoln,
got in the passenger seat
and they drove to school
and I didn't take 'em,
Christy didn't take 'em and no one had
to come back with the
car because she drove it.
She parked it.
She got out of it and
she walked into school.
I'm so proud of myself.
It took a lotta work.
This was not easy.
Now, I know that you had
resistance initially,
in this, the same resistance
that I am currently
experiencing, which is.
Way to go, me.
It's a different time, right?
And LA is also different
than where we grew up,
but it has been difficult to get our kids.
I cannot get Lock, who
will be 16 in February,
I cannot get him to begin Driver's Ed.
Oh, gosh.
Yeah, and he could've,
I think at 14 and a half
you can start takin' the class.
So, by 15 you're eligible
to get your learner's permit
and you have to have it
a certain amount of time.
And I'm the only person in my family
who is an advocate for this.
For some reason Lock doesn't
care 'cause he takes Uber.
Lilly was not motivated,
but I was very motivated.
I mean, I got two more kids in the house.
And, I'm not the one doin'
most of the runnin' around.
Christy would be like, I
feel like I'm a taxi driver.
She would make that
complaint and I would get it.
'Cause I mean, even on
the weekends or when I
would get home it would
be, you gotta pick up
this kid from here and you
gotta take this kid here.
Yeah, it's bull crap.
And we didn't do the
hop, skip and Uber thing
that you did, so we never got into that
because it was wasn't for
our family, okay, whatever.
So, we were takin' 'em around.
It's like, I gotta stay on it.
But, she wasn't motivated.
She's got a friend who I heard
her friend say it herself.
She's like, at this
point, I'm just waiting
until I turn 18 to get my
license because at that point
you can just get a license and there's
no restrictions on it.
You don't have to go
through all the rigamarole.
I just don't understand that.
Freedom, automobile represents freedom.
I know, and I had a really hard time,
I was not successful at giving Lilly,
to transfer any excitement,
any vision for that freedom
that we experienced when we turned 16.
We're just chompin' at the bit.
I mean, in October, when you turned 16.
I was at the DMV on my birthday.
Oh my gosh, man, and
I was waitin' for you,
you came to my house and picked me up
and we just rode nowhere.
It was wonderful.
The only thing that I
thought about for months.
Yeah, and we just drove around.
The idea that it's not a priority, again,
I know it's a different time.
I've heard this from many parents,
they're having trouble with their kids,
getting their kids to
care about, even kids
back in North Carolina.
Yeah, it's not just an
LA thing and you easily
just reduce it to like,
well, it's the screens.
And I think there is a
level of connectivity
that defrays the need to get in the car
and meet up with people or show up places
because you're constantly
into each other's feeds,
so you're constantly in each other's faces
or you're constantly in each
other's video game thingies.
Video game thingies.
But, even once we got in
the car and we started
driving around and realized
we had nowhere to go,
we weren't complaining.
We were reveling in just
driving nowhere for hours
listening to tapes and I
never really transferred
that passion to Lilly.
I just started to institute.
What do you mean trans, you can't.
That's not how it works.
No, I just started
instituting levels of bribery
and control.
Yeah, there's many
ultimatums that I've made.
Once you wouldn't be able
to drive yourself somewhere,
at that point you're
responsible for getting there
and that means financially, too.
You know, that's what I've said.
Okay.
I think this is where you
shot yourself in the foot
because among many other
things, like I said, bribery,
if you make it, you gotta do
like a 40 or 50 hour course
and then pass the test before you can get
your learner's permit.
Then you gotta go to the DMV.
It's never simple
at any point in the process.
But, because we never did
the Uber or there was never
any way for our kids
to get anywhere unless
we took 'em, and so I started to say,
when Lilly would say, I need to go here
or I need to pick up a
friend or I have to show up
for this thing or can you pick me up here,
I would be like, no, but I will point out,
if you had your license you could do this.
So, she started to feel the pain
of not being able to do some things
that she wanted to do.
It didn't happen a lot,
but it did happen some.
So, you don't have that card to play
because of the Uber thing.
He's not gonna pay, he
doesn't have any money
to pay for it.
Okay, so you just, then that does work.
He might be able to go what, one place.
Have you been doin' that?
No, I said when it,
I'm gonna, I don't know
what the timeline is.
Right now.
For when it's like, okay now at this point
I'm not taking you to this place
and if you wanna go
you have to pay for it.
Now.
Okay, I have to get my
wife onboard with this.
Here's the thing.
I don't know how your
wife thought about this.
My wife is so concerned about their safety
that she's like, you know, I don't know
if I want him driving in LA.
Like, what, he's gonna drive
in Los Angeles at some point.
Yeah, but the thing that
Christy told me was,
she was like, well, when
she does get her license
she can't drive that Sion, she's gotta get
a car with a backup camera.
And I'm like, backup camera?
I backed up, if you look at
all the times I've backed up
over the years, you could
back up around the moon twice
in the amount of times I've
backed up and I never once
had a camera.
It's questionable, but
you backed up a lot.
Never once had a camera.
In fact, you should learn to back up
without the camera before
you start using the camera.
'Cause I can tell you right now.
Cameras sometimes it doesn't work.
Sometimes it's raining and it gets blurry,
it gets foggy.
You gotta know how to back
up a car without the camera.
In fact, if you give your kid a car
that's got a backup camera.
You're handicappin' 'em.
At the beginning you need to put tape
over that backup camera.
Put tape over the backup
camera until they prove
that they can back up
and then take it off.
Like Stevie's webcam?
Stevie puts a Post-It note over a webcam.
Right.
Now, I am exclusively reliant
upon the backup camera.
I mean, I can back up
like at 78 miles per hour.
Like a grandma.
You can back 70?
I come down my driveway,
you know my driveway's
kinda steep and nuts.
Yeah, you don't give it a bit of gas
and you're going, you're
accelerating like a rocket.
Put the pedal to the metal
going downhill backwards.
Man, if there was a trashcan down there
you would obliterate it.
So, why was today the
first day that she drove?
She's had her license.
She hasn't wanted to?
She's had her license for a few months
and she's been well, to park at school,
it's all curb parking
and they do not teach
curb parking, they do not
require parallel parking
or curb parking as part
of the driving test.
Yeah.
So, I had to take her out
and start teaching her
to park on the curb to
prepare her, give her
the confidence to park and go to school.
There's no parking lot.
It's just street parking.
So, I took her out and first of all,
I never tell her, I'm just like,
we're going for a drive.
And then, I'm like okay,
I want you to park here.
It's like, dad, I don't
know how to parallel park.
It's like, exactly.
Now we're gonna do it.
Kids man.
It's like, why do they
say things like that?
Dad, I don't know how to parallel park.
Why the hell do you think we're here?
And are you okay with just
continuing on in your inability?
I don't understand.
I don't think that we were like that.
That firm.
Kids, these days.
And that is the reason why I was the one
doin' it and not Christy 'cause Christy,
she doesn't want to fuel Lilly's anxiety
as she's learning, but I'm like,
I'm kinda fed up so I'm very firm.
But, she responded positively
and she parallel parked.
I mean, we did it you know, 10 times.
And then, I was like, okay
now you can drive to school.
She's like, I don't feel comfortable.
So then, before the break
every day that I could
I would ride with her to school
and tell her where to park and I would
just be there to guide her through it.
But, we basically found a way,
a place where she could park on the curb
and be the last car so she wouldn't have
to do the parallel parking thing.
So, we found that and we
did that for a few days.
So yesterday, she was
parking, getting outta the car
and I was gettin' in and
driving the car back.
There was a couple of weeks of that.
Did she know that today was the day?
Yesterday she knew that, yeah.
And she did it and I was,
I wasn't totally ready.
I was in the shower and I was like,
oh man, she's about to leave for school
and I don't want Christy to take her.
I wanna make sure that she goes,
so I put a towel around my waist
and I got outta the shower
and I run downstairs as
she's yelling at Lincoln,
we gotta go, it's time to go,
which is every morning.
And they, so then I met
'em in my front yard.
I'm wearing nothin' but a towel
and I'm like, you can do this.
You can park.
You can go to school on your own.
Let's take a photo.
She refused the photo.
Smart girl.
But, I'm very proud of Lilly.
She did, I am proud of
myself, but I'm proud
of her, too, because she responded.
And you know what?
She's startin' to get it.
Right when we got back
from Thanksgiving break,
we're driving back from the airport,
she's like, when we get home I'm gonna go
see a friend of mine.
Yeah, exactly.
I'm like, yes, you go girl, you do that.
It's not just freedom.
I mean, first of all, it's illogical
because you are going to need to drive
at some point, right?
And so, the more experience you have.
Most people are going to need to drive
and the more experience
you have under your belt
the better you will be at things.
It's just like starting something earlier,
when you go back and
like, ah, I wish I had
taken up skiing before I was 25 years old
because you start doing
things that involve
coordination on some level.
The younger you start the better you are
for the rest of your life.
Yeah, like learning Japanese.
Not exactly, but similar.
But then, the freedom isn't just for them,
it's for you, the parent as well.
It's mostly about me.
I mean, I think I made
that abundantly clear.
I don't know what it is.
I know that our wives have a
significantly higher tolerance
for just doing things
for the kids than we do,
but I'm just like, Jessie, doesn't it just
frustrate the pure hell outta you
that you have to stop doing something
and take the kids somewhere?
I mean, for me, I guess I'm more selfish.
I'm just like, no, I don't wanna take you
anywhere right now.
Right.
I'm doing exactly what I wanna do.
But, the selfishness
lines up 'cause don't you
wanna just go?
It's a beautiful thing
when selfishness lines up
as a family.
I mean, I gotta re-evaluate, man.
I gotta get my wife onboard.
It did open up another
phenomena because she went
to her friend's house that night and then,
we're exhausted because
of the time change,
and I texted her and I was
like, when are you comin' back?
And she was like, I don't know.
And I was like, well, Jade's been confused
'cause you know I went and picked up Jade
from your house, thank
you for gettin' Jade
from the place, so I wouldn't have to wait
until the next day to
get Jade from the place,
from the kennel, the non-kennel kennel.
I really appreciate that.
That's bein' a good
friend, gettin' my dog.
It was pretty easy.
I was like, Jade hasn't
located you so she's
anxious, she's worried so you
need to come on back home.
She goes, well, I can
come back in 10 minutes
or I can come back right now.
It actually worked, but
then I realized I went down
and I took Jade and we were in her bed
waiting for her to get back,
just sittin' on her bed.
And so, it was now we've
moved to the waiting up phase
of kiddom and I didn't
think I'd be that guy,
the waiting up for you
to get home before I
go to sleep parent.
But, I kinda did it for
Christy because Christy
was exhausted and she was
like, when's Lilly coming back
and I know that she would
want one of us to stay up,
so I kinda did it for Christy.
I kinda did it for me, though.
So, I don't know if this is a new thing.
It doesn't sound selfish, it's weird.
I was waiting up for my child to get home.
Yeah.
I do think that there, I
do think we probably apply
different standards to how much you worry
about Lilly being out
late as a girl versus
Lock being out late as a guy.
But, there definitely have
been times when Jessie
and I have gone to sleep
and he's not back yet.
But, it's part of the plan.
Yeah.
Does he wake you up when he comes home?
He's like hey, I'm, back.
We tend to not be very plan-oriented
in the McLaughlin household.
He doesn't have a curfew?
Yeah, he can't stay out until whenever.
We know what he's doing
and where he's going
and I can locate him with
my phone or whatever,
but it's kinda like I know who you're with
and what you're doing
and there's a general
sort of expectation at
when you'll be back.
It isn't like oh, it's 1 a.m., I'm back.
And it's not a normal thing.
I'm just saying there have been times
when we just go to bed
and it's like all right,
we know where he's at.
He's coming home, he's
not spending the night
at this house.
I'm not saying it's wise, I'm just saying
that we tend to not be real concerned.
Okay, no judgment.
I'm just thinkin' I don't know if that's
where I'm headed next.
We haven't even gotten into
our Thanksgiving stuff,
so we should do that.
We will do that in a second, but first
we're going to encourage
you to go to mythical.com
and pick up things that you might like.
We got that, what are we
callin' the green hoodie?
Green wash.
Is it like a tie dye thing?
It's green, black.
It says what on it?
Mythical, GMM.
I mean, I have seen it, there's just a lot
of things over there.
You know how stuff sells
out, so get on over there
to mythical.com, check it out.
Check out all the other stuff.
And, you know what?
When we do weird things to sweatshirts
you guys buy them.
And so I don't know.
You like weird things done to sweatshirts,
so we'll keep doin' it.
Maybe.
Until we're tired of it.
Until you're tired of it.
We'll keep you guessin'
though at the same time.
Mythical.com.
Okay, let's talk about Thanksgiving.
We had pretty different Thanksgivings
because you went back to North Carolina,
saw family and I did not and I actually,
on the complete opposite
end of the spectrum,
I had people at my house
that I'd never met before.
Yeah.
For Thanksgiving.
How did that happen?
It was just people walking
by, I invited them in.
You told me you were
gonna fry two turkeys.
There's a woman that walks
backwards up the hill.
I was like, come on in and
tell me why you do that,
it's crazy.
Are you?
What?
Have you ever seen these
people who walk backwards?
What are you talkin' about?
There is a thing that
people do and I think
that there's probably a story behind it.
There are more than a few
people who walk backwards.
Up hills?
Some people walk backwards in general,
but people, in fact, there's a person,
she hasn't done it
recently, but Kelly Oxford,
writer, film maker, she on her Instagram
used to show this dude who was
walking backwards everywhere and it was
just flat surface, walking flat.
I haven't seen that, but there's at least
two people in my neighborhood
who walk backwards,
but they're always doing it uphill.
I don't know if they're like, I feel safe
'cause if I start falling I can catch.
I don't know what it is, but I saw a woman
this morning walking backwards.
There are two people in your neighborhood
who walk backwards uphill.
At least two.
And I don't know if one
started and the other one
said, this is a good idea.
I think this is a thing.
I think there's a philosophy to it,
to walking backwards uphill.
I can't come up with what that might be.
But, it was really just
a joke because I didn't
invite her in.
Those weren't the people that I invited.
It was just people who came with friends.
I think it might be a
physiological pain thing,
like a knee or ankle thing.
It doesn't hurt my knee
when I walk backwards.
Yeah, I'm sure we can figure it out.
Are they older people?
But, not now.
Over 40, which is me, I guess I'm old.
Well, and you told me that you were frying
two turkeys.
Three.
And I was a little worried about that.
Three?
Yeah, triple turkey.
Triple turkey.
So, you must have invited
a lot of strangers
to your house.
Well, it's a little complicated.
I assume that it's just people Jessie knew
that you didn't know.
No, no, no, no.
There were two people who
neither of us had ever met.
Isn't this what you said last year
that you didn't wanna do this year?
I probably did.
I say a lotta things.
You were talking about
Thanksgiving last year.
I don't like that my kids stay
out whenever they want to.
Bunch of people and you
were like, you know,
I think I'll do it differently.
Well, here's what I'll say.
You weren't at that
Thanksgiving last year, right?
Nope, I was at home.
I feel like I was playing
cards at a gas station.
I feel like I can speak more freely
about last year's Thanksgiving now
that we're a year out from it.
So, one of my friends
invited a lot of people
to a Thanksgiving celebration,
a friendsgiving, if you will,
but it wasn't really a
friendsgiving because it was
the majority of the people who were there
I felt like I didn't
know, or at least half.
I can't really remember, but
a lotta people I didn't know
and I didn't really mind it, but the thing
that really was a problem
was that they had gotten
this guy who was a chef
to make all the food
and it was like, the expectations
were really, really high,
but then he just did a really LA sort
of approach to things.
He did a dressing that is best described
as a deconstructed dressing.
It was kinda like pieces of bread that.
This is all recap.
I know, but I feel like it's a setup
for why I did things the
way I did 'em this year.
Okay.
And I did not, this is all new information
'cause I didn't talk crap about the food.
I'm doing that a year later.
Oh.
There were some vegan friends of mine
who brought a bunch of vegan desserts.
There wasn't even a fricking pumpkin pie
that wasn't, there was no butter in any
of the desserts.
It's just like, listen
y'all, Thanksgiving,
if just a couple of times
a year you're gonna let
it all hang out, let it all hang out.
Unzip it, unbutton it, unfurl it.
I get it, if you're a vegan you're not
gonna put butter in something,
but if you're not a vegan,
put butter in it and put a lot of butter
and a lot of sugar and
get it to taste good.
Let that be the goal.
So, you were focused on a traditional,
sugar and butter first, menu.
There was so much butter
and so much sugar.
And fried turkey.
And a lotta meat.
So, yeah, I deep fried three turkeys
and the reason I did three turkeys is
because when our friend, Jenny, found out
that I was deep frying turkeys,
she said, do you mind if I bring by
just a turkey breast and
you can fry that, too,
for my leftovers?
I love her.
And I was like, of course, I don't mind.
Okay, so you're counting her turkey breast
as, you got the vat, it's
hot, you might as well
dunk another.
Right, it was like, and I was almost like,
you know what?
I'll start with your turkey breast
because that'll be, it's a little bit
of a guinea pig.
It wasn't a guinea pig, it was a turkey,
but it would be like my test turkey.
And she was funny 'cause she was like,
my dad has this tradition
of completely cooking
a separate turkey breast
and that is your leftovers,
so there's not a lot of
pressure on the main turkey
to be left over.
Eat it all.
Then you have this completely
like prime turkey breast
that's ready to go.
And she was like, and can
you put this poultry magic
rub on it?
She gave me the rub.
She brought me the turkey
breast and the rub.
I was like, sure, no problem.
But, with the other two, and she got,
it was like a Butterball turkey.
It was a turkey that
was nice and packaged,
turkey breast nice and packaged.
It comes with, it's already got
a sodium and sugar solution in it,
so you don't need to brine it.
But of course, my wife gets
the Heritage Farm organic
never frozen turkey
that's been, this turkey's been massaged.
This turkey's probably
taken calculus classes
to get ready for this moment
and these turkeys were like $85 a piece
for a 13 pound turkey, just to
put things into perspective.
These were some expensive assed turkeys.
And it wasn't a bigger turkey
'cause the well treated
turkeys are smaller.
Right, they don't have those
giant antibiotic breasts.
They're just like pulsating,
ready to be eaten.
These are like a little more natural.
These turkeys have,
they've run around the yard
a little bit.
So, I was like, I gotta get this right.
These are some expensive turkeys.
And I did two turkeys
because I did the whole,
you roughly do a pound per person
and you're gonna get leftovers with that
and I was like, you know what?
I want a lotta leftovers and I want 'em,
if one turkey turns out
better than the other,
give me two turkeys.
So, I did the brining.
I brined it two days ahead of time.
I did the rub and I did all this homemade
and I followed the Pioneer Woman's recipe.
Me and the Pioneer Woman are like this.
Pioneer Woman.
She did a television show, didn't she?
Yeah, and so I followed her brining recipe
and her rubbing recipe
and then I injected.
I had my way with these turkeys.
I rubbed 'em, I injected
'em, I brined 'em.
I'm beginning to
understand why you invited
strangers over.
I spent way too much
time with those turkeys.
You can get away with more bragging
when people don't know you that well,
they'll sit and listen to
you brag about what you did
to your turkeys for hours.
No, I actually had a lot
of self-deprecating talk
about the turkeys because
I was nervous about 'em.
Because, what is the one
thing that everyone's
worried about with turkey?
What is the one thing that
people like you ham men
complain about?
You don't want a dry turkey.
It's too dry.
And, my theory is that
it isn't that people
don't like turkey.
It's that people don't like dry turkey
and that most people and a lot of people
who do not like turkey have been deprived
of adequately moist turkey and therefore,
they've come to wrong
conclusions about turkeys.
It isn't actually dry if you do it right.
So, I'm deep frying these things.
I haven't done that in like 15 years,
one time Chris and I did
it back in North Carolina,
but it was different.
I got the electric fryer, so I didn't do
the whole gas situation.
I read the statistic
that 4300 people a year
burn their homes down
frying, deep frying turkeys,
which sounds like a
made up stat, but I saw
it on many websites, so it must be true.
So, this is basically
like a giant deep fryer
that has a lid and everything.
Got the oil, peanut oil, put it in there.
It's all about gettin' the
right level on that oil.
Well, they make it easy.
There's a min line and a max line
and it basically said if your turkey
is a certain size or certain pounds,
if you put it at the max
line it'll be covered,
so I did that and it was fine.
Finished that first turkey.
It looked great.
Did the second one and the third one.
It was not easy to hold,
get the temperature
anyway, I was a little bit worried
'cause I thought I went a little too long.
But, boy the turkey talk started as soon
as people started biting
into those breasts.
And of course, I had, I did dark meat
and white meat on the platter,
dark meat on one side,
white meat and I did the whole thing.
Me and Nick, we sat
there and we trimmed it.
We took all the meat off.
Do you have an electric cutter?
Jenny, the way that she
paid for her turkey is
she let me use her electric knife.
And so, I cut it up.
It had a little bit of the
brine flavor was coming through
'cause I put some orange peel in there,
only because the Pioneer
Woman wanted me to
and I do whatever she says.
She'd strangle a wolf.
Yeah, all I can say is
the turkey was a success
and I'm very proud of myself.
I mean, it was the moistest breast
this side of the Mississippi.
I'm sure east of the Mississippi there was
some very moist breasts because the people
in the south can really cook.
The Pioneer Woman is west
of the Mississippi as well.
Is she on the Plains?
Yeah, she's cookin' up a turkey this year.
And Jessie was like, well,
you're in trouble now
because you've gotta do that again.
You have to do this every year.
That we're here because
you've shown that you can.
Like living, like above the ground.
The problem, it took so much time.
In fact, I actually had this whole idea
that I was going to
Instagram this process.
I had a whole character, Terry
and his Turkey Tutorials,
I had a whole character.
I had a pair of glasses,
a whole thing that I was gonna do.
And as soon as I got into
looking at the directions,
I was like, oh gosh, I
don't have the ability
to be entertaining and do this right.
Maybe next year, Terry
and his Turkey Tutorials
will be back, will be
there for the first time,
because now I understand
what I'm up against.
Turkey Terry had to tarry until 2020.
But, it was a success.
But, the phenomenon of,
and just so you know,
I'm gonna talk about my Thanksgiving
and then I'm gonna hand it over to Link
and he's gonna talk all
about his Thanksgiving,
so I'm not intentionally
hogging the conversation.
We have a plan.
Don't bring a hog into this.
Keep your turkey.
You did have a hog on your
Thanksgiving, I assume.
But, you didn't have, man I should've kept
some of that breast behind for you
so you could see how moist it is.
But anyway, having people.
I'm a ham man.
I wasn't particularly, I like to save
the ham for Christmas.
That's the thing.
I'm a Christmas ham and
they're so close together,
the holidays are so close together,
they're like a month apart,
so I feel like ham, ham.
Can a ham man have too much ham?
I feel like they can.
I don't.
I wasn't super excited about having people
that I didn't know because I tend to be
a hermit and a loner and I'm the kinda guy
that when there's a bunch
of people in my house
I go upstairs for a little bit.
I'm that guy.
But my wife is my wife, as you know,
and she's the most welcoming
and hospitable person
on the face of the planet and will talk
to a stranger into like 4 a.m.
And so, I was like, no, this is good.
This, meaning what?
Having people that I don't know.
It's great.
Well, how do people
you don't know show up?
They knew people that I do know.
So okay, it's like bring other people.
It's like, hey.
We're in LA.
You invite one, you invite this one family
and they're like, we
were gonna get together
with so and so, can we bring them?
Oh, and she was gonna bring so and so
and he might bring so and so.
It's the chain effect.
Yeah.
And we were like, sure.
Must have been 18 people, whatever.
But, it was great.
And the thing that, it
was nice getting to know
new people, but it also
created this dynamic
where we had not planned
on, what are we doing?
We knew what time we were
gonna eat approximate.
Of course, we ate later than that.
We were eatin' kinda late.
We were eating at 6 o'clock.
So all right, what about
Thanksgiving night?
How long are people gonna stay?
People with kids kinda started
peelin' off, peelin' out.
And then, a few people
stayed and we were like,
let's watch a movie.
And I don't know who suggested it.
Somehow we decided that we
were gonna watch Footloose.
Footloose.
Footloose, Kevin Bacon, 1984, I guess.
Have you seen that?
I'm an American, yes.
I have not seen that.
Sounds painful.
It's like your foot's loose.
Is this a medical drama?
God, my foot's loose.
Must be with the ankle, I don't know.
I haven't seen Footloose since that wave
in the '80s where most people
were watching Footloose,
so I kinda knew, I've seen it.
I know about the famous
speech to the City Council
and stuff like that
that you see on YouTube
and that kinda thing.
And of course, the dances.
I know about the dances in socks.
That's really at the beginning.
In fact, most of that close foot action.
Or is that Tom, is Tom Cruz in that?
No, you're thinkin' about
Risky Business probably
where he's dancing with just a shirt.
Do you know that John Lithgow is in,
he plays the pastor.
Because the story of
Footloose is that this
sort of super conservative
Midwestern town,
which I actually thought
was really interesting
in light of Bleak Creek, and this story,
I didn't think about Footloose one time
when we were writing Bleak Creek.
You know I didn't.
Because you've got this
super conservative town
where the pastor has a lotta control.
He won't let 'em dance?
And you can't dance.
Oh.
And Kevin Bacon comes in, new kid
from outta town and of
course, dancin' is his thing.
And it's a story of him tryin'
to get the town to dance.
That's a Thanksgiving movie.
Now, it isn't a Thanksgiving movie, right,
but I discovered something
that I've never heard
anybody point out.
I almost tweeted it, but then, that takes
a little more effort.
Turkey Terry didn't feel like tweeting.
At the end of the movie, spoiler alert,
there's a dance.
The town gets to dance.
At the dance the camera is moving across
the spread of food that's at the dance
and the food at the dance is unlike
any food at any dance there has ever been
'cause it's like whole
baked pies and cakes.
Thanksgiving.
And then, as the camera tilts up
and you see in the background at the end
of the table, a turkey.
There is a turkey on the table.
It's Thanksgiving.
It's a Thanksgiving movie,
but it's not Thanksgiving.
It's just their dance.
And I was like, has anybody
ever noticed this before?
There's a turkey.
And then, I thought about
pausing it and rewinding
it to make sure that it was a turkey,
but then I was like, what if I rewind
and it's not a turkey?
That'll ruin it for me.
Plus, there's strangers watching.
Turkey Terry.
Who's this guy pausing
the movie at the end
and rewinding it?
It was funny though, 'cause
it's one of those things,
it's one of those things that happens
that feels like a glitch in the matrix
because Turkey Terry
has spent all this time
on the turkeys, getting
the turkeys just right.
He's seein' turkeys everywhere.
And then, all of a sudden
he's watchin' Footloose
and there's a turkey on the table.
What are the chances?
This is a glitch in the matrix.
100%.
And I want that glitch to remain
and I do think that it's true
that there is a turkey on the table.
There's pies on the table
and there's a large, brown
baked bird at the end of the table.
It's Thanksgiving.
So, Footloose is a Thanksgiving movie
and you know what?
Shepherd watched it with me,
watched it with us 'cause Jessie and I
and then whoever else was left
and he was into it.
We learned things.
Kevin Bacon, Kevin Bacon
has really held up.
You know the thing that you do now
when you watch movies and you're looking
at an actor and you're like, it's 1984,
how old was he then?
How old is he now?
And then you start looking
at modern pictures of people.
Same.
You start seeing how
the actors in the movie
have aged and you find
out, oh, Chris Penn,
Sean Penn's brother, who
plays his friend, he's dead.
He died in 2006.
Oh, that's sad.
And then, you're like what
does Kevin Bacon look like?
Whoa, Kevin Bacon looks good.
What has Kevin Bacon been
doing to look so good?
Not eatin' bacon, I'll tell you that.
Dancin'.
So, and then that.
Do you wanna hear about my Thanksgiving?
Yeah, the only, the last thing I'll say is
that watching a movie
on Thanksgiving night
opened up the floodgates
and ended up seeing
more movies in a shorter period of time.
We went to the theater twice,
saw Knives Out, highly recommend it.
And then, I already told you about this,
saw Ford vs. Ferrari, which is the ratio
of how much I wanted to see a movie
to how good it was.
I didn't want to see that movie at all.
It's like a racing movie, I don't care.
Ford vs. Ferrari, you gotta see it.
It's a great movie.
Don't make that face.
Have you seen it?
You need to see it because
of course, it's got
great actors in it, but it's just
a really compelling story.
My kids loved it.
I loved it.
Jo Jo Rabbit is the best
movie of the year so far.
We already talked about that.
But, I saw that before Thanksgiving.
What about your Thanksgiving, Neil?
I didn't have, I didn't have a turkey.
I mean, I'm tryin' not to, you know what?
I'm gonna try and make this introspective
and not a downer, but I think the spoiler
is some downer elements
to my Thanksgiving.
So, it's not bright eyed and bushy tailed
like your Footloose
Turkey Terry shenanigans.
Footloose and fancy free.
We didn't have, you know,
we went to my nanny's house.
It's like, she and Aunt
Vickie, we didn't wanna burden
them and have 'em make food.
So Nanny, she's not able to
make her signature dressing
that, that dressing that we would get
that like, slather that
gravy on it every year.
I grew up eatin' that.
It was like the perfect
Thanksgiving dressing.
Has she written the recipe down?
'Cause that's how, you gotta
hold on to those recipes.
That's a good point.
Recipes from your relatives,
it's really, really important
that they write those down.
That's one of the ways that we remember
Jessie's grandmother is make those cakes
that she used to make.
Yeah, that's a good point
because she's not able to
make that and we didn't
wanna burden them to have to make stuff,
so we brought in Bojangles.
That's a good Thanksgiving.
My kids were just so excited.
'Cause they knew we had planned this.
We're gonna get Bojangles for Thanksgiving
at Nanny's house.
And so, that's quite a silver lining.
I mean, it's not a Thanksgiving meal,
but it's Bojangles and we never get that.
So, it was pretty great.
But, they're not doing well, so it's like,
and we're talkin' to Nanny about,
she's like, I gotta pull my will together.
That's fun table talk.
So, here we are on Thanksgiving.
We're tryin' to, we're
talkin' about the finer points
of the will, which is
a very important thing
to talk about and we had been
talkin' about it leading up
to Thanksgiving, but
since we were together
in the same room we were
talkin' about it a little bit.
So, it tends to be a
bit of a downer talkin'
about a will, but it's
also very important.
Unless you're a lawyer.
Yeah,
So, that was kinda the vibe this year.
There was no going to a gas
station and playing cards.
We had planned things out a little better,
but also mom and Lewis
weren't able to show up
because of Lewis's health
and actually the last time
I talked about it on Ear Biscuits, I guess
it was the whole episode devoted
to their visit out here and how he
basically almost died, right.
And then, he recovered well enough
that they were able to fly back home
and then I remember tellin the story
that when he got home he was blowin' off
his garage with the leaf blower.
Good, good, good.
Well, I haven't talked
about it since then,
but the update there is a
few days after that he had
a series of strokes.
You know about this,
but they don't, so I'll
just kinda bring 'em up to speed.
And again, that was back in April.
So, ever since April he's been in and out
of the hospital and rehab facilities
in order to regain the ability to walk
and gain the strength to do things.
And he's, it's been very difficult,
but right before we came back home
for Thanksgiving was the first time
that he came back home since April.
He's been in and out of
facilities this whole time.
Just when you were home?
Yeah.
I mean, back in July when we went home,
when we were filming at Buies Creek
for the Bleak Creek
conversation documentary
that is now on Mythical
Morning, we would film
there in the day and
then every night I would
go visit mom and Lewis in
the hospital and he was,
he was basically, he was on a ventilator.
Ventilator may not be the right word.
He had a feeding tube
and he was not conscious.
It was bad.
He had four or five
near death experiences,
once leaving LA since April.
And so, this was the first
time seein' him in person
and he finally has gotten back home,
which is great news.
So, he is on a road to recovery,
but they weren't able to
come to Nanny's house.
We had Thanksgiving, Bojangles at Nanny's
and then later that
afternoon we went to Mom's
and saw Lewis and he'd lost 65 pounds.
He looks like a totally different person.
Yeah.
You know, it's like, I mean, he looked
a whole lot better than
he did when I saw him
all swollen and in the
hospital every night
when I'd visit them in July.
So, in a way it was difficult,
but it was also very good
to see him at home and know
that he had just been there
a few days and they were
very thrilled to be there.
I mean, you go, we've learned
so much through the process.
We're just talkin' to my
mom multiple times a week
and just seeing how slowly things move
when you're trying to recover like that.
But, for him to be back at
home was a big milestone.
So, it was certainly one
of the biggest headlines
for us all to be grateful
for seein' him there.
For his side of the family,
he's got all his siblings
that he wanted to visit.
So, there was a question
whether he'd be able
to leave the house and have
enough strength to go visit.
Is he walking?
He can walk some, but he just, his body
kinda wasted away as he was dealing
with a series of infections that led
to the near death experiences
that I was talkin' about.
So yeah, it's just physically
gaining the strength
to be able to walk, but he can stand.
He can get in a wheelchair.
They're doin' therapy at
home where he's continuing
to regain strength, but he was able
to go visit and be with his family
when they got together on the next day.
So, it was difficult going home.
And then, we go to
Nanna's house and we had
a big Thanksgiving spread there.
It was absolutely amazing.
And I remember talkin'
about our highlights
of the year last year that Mom and Lewis
came to that.
They came to my Nanna's
house, my dad's mom's,
I talked about that.
But of course, they weren't
able to come to that.
And there's a sense of,
when you only go back home,
even at Nanna's where it
was a lot more positivity,
it's still like okay,
there's still, you know,
it's the second Thanksgiving
without my uncle
and without papaw,
Nanna's lifelong partner.
So, there's a sense of loneliness and loss
that still is very much there.
And I think it was
important for us to be there
and to talk about that, some part of it.
So, it's like, you find yourself talkin'
about those things as
well and my aunt saying
she felt like that this
Thanksgiving was worse
than the previous one
because when Thanksgiving
rolled around last year
she was still in shock
over the loss of her husband.
So, in a lotta ways it was like oh, this
is the new normal for us.
But, you try to see it not
as, I'm tryin' to see it not
as much as a downer, oh isn't this sad,
but more like, it's sobering and it does
provide an occasion for us to say
what we can still be thankful for.
But, it's not easy to do that.
But I do think we tried
to, we tried to make
the best of it.
We dug out those, remember
those old cornhole boards?
When we did that commercial
for AJJ Cornhole,
not the cornhole song, but we also did
a commercial for them?
We shot it at your grandmother's yard.
In their yard.
It's time you play Cornhole.
Cornhole gives me confidence.
Well, I was going through
their shed out there
and I found the Cornhole
set in the corn bags
and they weren't all moldy and
we sat out there and played.
It says AJJ Cornhole on the Cornhole.
That was on ours, but apparently we got
a buncha free sets and we
left one at Nanna's house.
So, we're out there playing Cornhole
and havin' a good time.
But, there's, it's also
difficult when you just
go back as a family once
a year, maybe twice.
But, the last time we
had been back as a family
was last Thanksgiving.
So, you go back, it's been a whole year,
everybody's a year older
and the older you are
the more palpable that age
piling on is, you know.
It's like sobering in that way.
I got more gray every year.
So then I just found
myself starting to think
more about man, as my relatives get older,
you start to think about,
what does care look like?
What does care for my mom look like
as she has no siblings
and I have no siblings
and I live out here in Los Angeles?
It's like, if it was
her going through that
and not Lewis, as much
as I'd try to be there
for her long distance over the phone
and provide support, how
would that be different
if it was mom that was havin' the strokes?
I guess there's a lot to plan for.
It's like, you can't over plan for things
that you don't know exactly.
You just gotta be ready for the unexpected
and take it as it comes, right.
But, I just couldn't help but start
to think about, as relatives,
as loved ones get older,
how do you start to interact with them?
And there's a lotta technicalities,
like what you're talkin' about.
You know, with your Nanny, who's, well,
she's in her 80s, right?
Yeah.
And she's getting her
will stuff together now,
which is, this is what a
lot of people do, right,
because there's not just the will.
She had one, but then
you gotta update it, too.
So, it's not that she didn't have one,
but it needed to be drastically updated
'cause it had been so long.
And then, there is the end
of life care questions.
Who's gonna take.
At this point everybody's still kind of,
no one's by themselves 'cause
your Nanny has her sister
and then Lewis has your mom.
Right.
My parents have each other.
So, it's like, what about when they don't?
Yeah, and for that stuff, for all of that
that happened to Lewis,
that was so unexpected
at his age, you know.
Especially when you have
grandparents that are living.
Every year, for years
we go back and say well,
you kinda think in the back of your mind,
it's like, is this the
last, is this the last year
that you see the oldest relatives?
But then, there's the
things that last year
that blind sided us.
And then, this year, that blind
sided us with what happened
to Lewis, so it's again, I
don't have any firm conclusions.
I'm trying to find, there's still a lot
to be thankful for and I think we are
and I'm certainly glad that we went home,
but it's, I don't know, it's a reminder
that as much as you can't plan for it,
there's some things you can like havin'
your will in place and talking about it
so that people know what your wishes are.
I think it's good for all of us.
I know that we had to pull
our wills together years ago.
The younger you are the more fun it is
to pull your will together
'cause it makes you
feel good that you're
gettin' it outta the way.
But the older you get, it starts to feel
a little bit more bleak, you know.
People just don't, I mean, a lotta people
just put that stuff off.
They don't wanna have those conversations.
I mean, just the conversation
that you have to have,
as you get to be middle
age, the conversation
you have to have with your parents about,
it would be a conversation I would have
with my parents and also my brother.
You figure out, okay, what are we gonna,
when it gets to a place where our parents
can't take care of themselves,
what does that look like?
Yeah.
One of them gonna be
livin' with you, with me?
Are they gonna be, are we gonna find some
kinda care for them?
Those are really difficult
conversations to have,
but you kinda, what you don't wanna do is
you don't wanna be having
to have those conversations
in the midst of the crisis.
Right.
I sound like an insurance salesman.
But, I mean it's true, you know.
You gotta have those
difficult conversations.
Right.
But I mean, we're stayin'
with Christy's sister
and we had a great time there.
And then, it's nice 'cause
my nephew, Nehemiah,
he's like a little nut runnin' around.
So, it's nice to have the kids in the mix.
He and Lando were havin' a great time.
But yeah, it was a bit of,
I don't know, also not being there,
so then, when you go back it's like,
oh wow, it's like, everybody's older.
Ain't nobody gettin' younger.
So, it just feels, it feels like man,
you're not an active part
of your loved ones lives
or you're a much less active part of it
just because of the shear
distance associated with it.
And it's just the way it is.
And I think at this point
it's the life that we live.
It's not unusual.
It's not wrong.
But, you know what it is?
It's very unusual in the
course of human history
because it isn't until very recently,
like a blink of an eye in the time scale
of human history where people
like, what do you mean?
You don't live at the same
place with your parents?
Yeah.
Everyone did that.
And obviously, that's still
the case in a lotta cultures,
but especially here.
It's the exception to
the rule if you live.
A lot of people are still
kind of close in proximity,
but a lotta people were
actually in the same homes
with multi-generational homes.
Yeah, I don't know.
We haven't really figured out what,
like the expectation that,
I think the expectation
still holds that your family
is gonna be responsible
for your care in one sense,
but that doesn't mean
what it meant for most of history,
which is directly
responsible for your care.
It's more like, no, no,
we're gonna get someone
who's job it is to care for old people.
I mean, there's a huge industry, right?
Right.
It's just, it's a weird
thing because it wasn't
ever like that.
It wasn't oh, there are
people whose job it is
to come to our village and
take care of the old people.
No, we do that.
Yeah.
And I haven't, again, I'm starting,
I've been prompted
because of this experience
to think about it, but
it's not like I've started
to figure it out.
But I do know that I'm not
like, well, I wouldn't,
that sounds gross, or
I would never do that
or passing preemptive judgment
on what other people do.
I know it's gonna be complicated.
But, thinking about it
a little bit at a time
is better than just
continuing to put it off.
So, I think that's one
of the applications.
And I think another one is just being,
I'm very grateful that we went back
and that the time that we
spent there was quality.
It was special at each place.
I remember, I choose to
hang on to the moments
and the memories like when I dozed off
after eating all the
Bojangles on the couch bed
that Nanny sleeps on in the living room.
And I woke up to Lando and
my aunt just dying laughing
because Lando was showing her how to use
the face filter thingys on I don't know
if it's Snapchat or Instagram.
I don't even use that stuff.
But, she was cackling.
This was her first experience with it.
First experience with it.
So, it's like you eat
your food, you doze off
and then you wake up
to that and it's like,
that's what we're here for.
Here for those moments when.
Here for those filters.
You're here for those
moments when everybody
can share laughing, everybody can share,
yeah, we know we're sharing the hurt
of whatever it is that we're all feeling,
but then at the same
time, we can also laugh
at how stupid we look with
these face filters on.
Did, was there turkey
served at Nanna's house?
Yeah.
So, some people did consume turkey.
But, my dad brought a pork,
he had smoked a pork,
a bunch of pork loins
the week before for somethin' else
and he had a few more.
So, he heated one of those up and that's
what I ate and it was amazing.
Ham man.
Got a lot to be thankful for.
Yeah, I'm thankful for
everything that we've had
and the things that we don't have anymore,
I'm thankful that I once had it
and there was still a lot that we did have
and to be had.
And carry that spirit of thankfulness
through the seasons.
Don't just be thankful
one day outta the year.
Be thankful every day.
Be thankful that another day has happened
and you're a part of it.
Yeah, speaking of that, we're gearing up
for our top 10s of the year.
That's the next episode, right?
The last episode of the
year, the next episode
yeah, we're gonna do
the top 10 best moments
of each of us in 2019.
Personal, professional, otherwise.
What else is there?
You gonna shut 'em down with a rec.
I gotta rec.
It's a podcast.
You might be familiar with Radiolab
which is one of my
favorite podcasts already.
Well, Jad Ubamrad, one of
the, I'm probably saying
his name wrong, is one of
the hosts of that show,
was gonna do an episode
or so about Dolly Parton.
And then, when he got into the process
he realized that there
was a whole podcast.
So now there's a podcast
called Dolly Parton's America,
which I think is still a limited series,
seven or eight episodes, in right now.
But, I've been listenin' to it.
I love it.
And, it's not just, because it's not just
about the details of the
history of Dolly Parton
and her career, but it's
how an icon like her
has built this audience
and then what she has done,
what that says about our
country and the state
that we're in right now and
the polarization of America
and the political divide and how Dolly has
sort of overcome that in certain ways
and why that might be.
I don't even know exactly
where they're goin' with it,
but it's just a really
insightful, personal podcast.
I've always been a fan of Dolly Parton.
I mean, I've been to Dollywood.
I've made the pilgrimage.
She's a special lady.
All right, Dolly Parton's America.
Dolly Parton's America
I recommend it.
Hashtag EarBiscuits, let
us know what you think
about the conversations we had today
and I gotta get outta here 'cause I have
to not pick up my
daughter from high school.
High school.
Keep being grateful.
Keep being thankful.
Speak at you next week.
Never stop.
To watch more Ear Biscuits
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous episode
of Ear Biscuits click on
the playlist to the left.
And, don't forget to
click on the circular icon
to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for bein' your mythical best.